I'm here at the Soho Theatre with Judah
Friedlander who's here to do his
stand-up show Judah Friedlander world
champion that you that this is your
second time doing stand-up in London
isn't it what's it like to be back it's
great I like it here you have a good
town you know the the people in the
Queen have done a good job with this
city I enjoy it now you like doing
stand-up in New York take this very
diverse audience how does London compare
for you London's a pretty diverse city I
don't know if it's quite as diverse as
New York it's uh it's a cleaner City
it's not open quite as late and better a
better subway the tube here works a
little better than in New York and the
cab drivers are a lot better oh yeah
yeah and it's cool I like it a lot it's
great city I want to know about the cab
drivers why are they better here than in
New York have you been in a cab in New
York very few times yeah well here they
actually won you can talk with them a
lot of the cab drivers in New York
neither don't know English they don't
know it that well but most of them now
they're not even interested in having a
conversation they're actually on their
cell phone the entire time and if you
try to talk to them they get mad at you
because you're interrupting their
conversation yeah so I like to talk so
you don't really get to talk with them
you know and and the guys here generally
know where everything is they've three
they have three years of school do they
realize in New York they've got the
world champion in their cab maestro I
sure I should just ride cabs for their
security purpose so what can people in
London expect from the show this year
Duda you know it's tough they can't
there's nothing they can prepare for you
know it's the most incredible experience
they're ever gonna have and they they
can't expect it because they've never
experienced it before so they just got
to come check it out
the world champion of of the world
that's why above champion it says world
in everything ever no no not not math
not things like reading you know those
those are some of my only deficiencies
okay world champion weaknesses as it
were if you had to put it that way yeah
now I'd like to know if the world
champion could find anyone who were
these toughest fight be do you think
there's nobody out there that can touch
me there's just there really isn't
really how about how about like if we've
got the Avengers like all together you
know Iron Man Captain America ya know
there you know you see the thing in the
here's why you know superheroes are not
good fighters because one a lot of them
have gadgets as soon as you have a
weapon that means you're not good and
then they usually have like one thing
that like kind of makes them powerful
and you take away that one thing and
then I've got no weaknesses you know
besides math I mean I guess if you if
you started reading me math equations I
might get a little Luisi and maybe pass
out or something you know but that
that's really about it plus they have
like secret identities
you know like Superman has to like I
don't hide the fact that you hide means
you have a weakness and you're not
really a good fighter you ever tie zits
on your t-shirt it's on the hat and you
know you're out there
yeah when you're the world champion you
don't have to hide it I wouldn't know if
Superman flew in here now how would you
take him down as the world champ
obviously well first I'd I'd hook up
with Lois Lane right in front of them
just to emotionally humiliate him and
the rest would just be just standard
karate you know he doesn't know karate
and of course you've written a book on
it haven't you yeah I do have a book
called how to beat up anybody I have it
here with me actually yeah I'm liking
this better proud a copy I'm not gonna
let you hold it because this weighs 500
kilos yeah I can feel the weight just
from here yeah once you've each page
weighs about three kilos its 208 pages
and it's a big book the book itself is a
weapon actually and after you read the
first chapter you'll be strong enough to
hold it up on your own you get you get
that powerful that quickly what if
you're fighting someone who is also read
the book you'll still win because each
one that this book is not mass-produced
each one was specifically written for
the specific person who buys that book
it's destiny
yeah how do you know in advance like if
I went out to buy this book that it's
specifically for me because I can't
explain it to you you know the levels of
karate and inside I have a you know
regular humans just won't understand it
so I appreciate that because I don't
mind literally blowing yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I mean I can do that but I yeah well I
stand for justice I think I would ask
you to do some cross in use but I know
that you move it's such speed that our
camera wouldn't pick them up no you were
very good technology here but it's not
up to what I'm doing the Queen has
banned me from doing karate during the
day yeah do you do a bit of crossing at
night yes I can still do karate at night
and what about ninjas you got ninjas in
there years and shadows dinosaurs also
Wow I teach this on page 12
this technique that's page 12 I mean I'm
kind of wondering what's on page 200
night if that's already on page 12 yeah
it's this book is just ahead of its time
even if you're from the future so will
you be talking about any of your karate
moves on stage do you think you'll be
blowing the audience man yeah I I will
talk a little bit about my martial arts
career yeah you know in general the fans
like that so I I will talk about that
yeah here's a whole chapter about ninja
attacks and home invasions of ninjas and
how to defeat them because you never
know when that's gonna happen do you
want to be ready well with the economic
downturn it's affected the ninja
community as well so they're not just
striking at night they're striking
during the day so you have to be
prepared that your Moscow do you think
yeah you definitely have to preparation
is key for success now I want to talk a
bit more about your hands because I know
you've got very very many hats that you
were literally and figuratively let's
talk about the literal hats do you make
them all yourself and how long does it
take one of the hats like when I did the
show 30 rock I made all of those hats
and I came up with all the sayings on
the hats this hat here where what I do
stand up all the hats I wear what I do
stand up or
made by me there there presented to me
by the world championship committee in
different countries where I've won the
World Championships big all know that
it's like having a gold cup or something
yeah exactly it's much more important
than that yeah but yeah you can take
them wherever you go as well Gold Cup
would be a bit inconvenient wouldn't it
yeah nobody else couldn't wear these
it's kind of like King Arthur's sword
you know it only this hat actually
weighs 700 kilos so I would kill a
normal person but my neck muscles are
very strong well you weren't well my
friend you were we weren't well now with
30 rock you mentioned though you were a
series regular there of course of 7
years weren't you what was it like being
part of that and what do you think was
Frank's finest hour
it was a long process it was it felt
like seven years it's because it was
seven years and yeah Frank you know he
did a lot of good things he co-created a
porno video game that's one of his
greatest accomplishments he did fairly
well with the ladies often with the
elder ladies and I think it's important
to help the elderly and I think Frank
certainly did his part you know that
goes unrecognized a lot you know and I'd
say that that's probably it
you know those two things was it like
working with the guys like Tina Fey and
Alec Baldwin Jane Krakowski and Tracy
Morgan on there as well it was all good
you know everyone kind of comes from
different backgrounds and stuff so it
was it was fun working with everybody
Tracy was the only person who I'd known
before doing the show everyone else was
new so it was great he's not three
stunned that was it yeah yeah yeah you
know you know all the comics who network
out of New York you know eventually you
bump into everybody you know so Tracy
I'd known a little bit over the years
what would you like to see in half an if
the show had continued what would you've
liked Frank to have gone on and done oh
well you know I always liked doing as if
I'm acting I like doing different things
I don't like doing the same thing over
and over again so my favourite episodes
are the ones where they let me do stuff
that was different you know I turned gay
for
guy for one episode yeah that was great
one episode I started morphing into Liz
Lemon that was great and then I was
trying to become a corporate lawyer for
a while so so I really liked storylines
where they let me just completely change
and so I would have liked to have seen
more than that I mean even throughout
you know what do you think Frank would
have been like as a corporate lawyer cuz
he was going down that route wasn't he
but it was too dangerous for him as his
mum said you know Frank was an odd
character cuz you know he was if you if
you really analyzed the guy he was very
he never really had a core or a real
sense of who he was he was very easily
manipulated you know he stuck to his own
thing but he was also easily manipulated
I mean the fact that he actually turned
gay he turned a 100% homosexual and then
he went right back to being heterosexual
it's almost like he's got some kind of a
you know a personality disorder you know
and then he was really considering just
leaving the life of writing on a comedy
show and watching porno and playing
video games all day to becoming a
legitimate corporate lawyer so so yeah
and then so and so yeah he's an odd guy
you know I think he's a guy who who
thinks he knows he is but he really
doesn't know who he is at all I don't
think Frank has truly found himself yet
he continued them with I think it's a
mystery that may never get solved you
offered studio 60 on the Sunset Strip
point you at the same time as 30 welcome
people actually saying to you go is
talking yeah yeah parent a fair amount
of people wanted me to do that show it
was even a smaller part that I did on 30
rock and to me 30 rock was the easy
choice so that's what I did and I
actually met Sorkin who created studio
60 on the Sunset Strip a few years later
and he came up to me was I think was at
a party for the award show in Los
Angeles and he came up to me he's like
boy did you make the right decision so
that was like really cool you know
what's your favorite hat that you came
up with for the show
I I made a hat and it was half accident
it's a trapdoor
and the hats I would make up 30 rock
we're very simple most of them are just
you know stick on letters onto the Hat
and so it wrote a trap then I wrote door
and then accidentally one of the O's
fell off so it was trap and then do a
blank space and then are and that was
like and then Paul who was a one of the
Wardrobe guys came in he saw the Hat and
he's like oh that's brilliant and I'm
like what I'm like oh yeah so it's it's
like the Oh
the second Oh fell through the trapdoor
that was on the Hat so that that's I
think that was my favorite one so it was
half accident half thought out and of
course we know you for your films as
well too and we've been in loads of
films over the years and you've got more
coming up as well tell us about the new
ones coming up well I didn't know I had
more coming up but that's the cool you
said that it's gonna be let me see that
is ping-pong summer coming yeah I did a
movie called ping-pong summer hopefully
it'll come out it was fun to do
I love playing ping-pong I will be
playing some ping-pong here in one dead
while I'm in town I got my paddle with
me and the next few projects I'm gonna
do our just my own I'm gonna make a
stand-up comedy album and I'm gonna make
my own stand-up comedy movie slash
documentary so it's gonna be a first few
isn't cuz you're not denying this before
yeah I've always kind of turned them
down or just been to organize to do them
myself so I don't definitely get out
this year and I heard this may be a
prequel to Oaxaca merican Simoes yeah
you know they were talking about that
and they were getting kind of close to
it and now I think they're a little far
away from it I think it's a lot of
scheduling stuff so hopefully it'll
happen that would be great all the same
guys back together again yeah it would
be all the same people yeah yeah so
hopefully that will happen
turned into big cult movie didn't it
yeah it's got a nice cult following and
I just think I like their idea of doing
a prequel using the same actors but it's
10 years later you know I think that's
cool now anything else you'd like to say
about your standard coming up at the
Soho Theatre in London you know I'm
excited to be here and looking forward
to
and yeah I think it's me a sexy time is
it gonna be part of your continuing
presidential platform do you think I
will definitely talk about my
presidential platform in the United
States as well as my possible
presidential campaign for England as
well yeah what would you like to do here
well I'm gonna let the people ask me the
questions and I'm gonna try to come up
with solutions tonight and tomorrow and
Wednesday yeah it cats you at the Soho
Theatre then don't miss it yeah I'm
gonna I'm sometimes when I'm performing
I actually step off stage and watch some
of the show too because it's such an
exciting show and you are that fast that
we wouldn't even notice Huntley no you
wouldn't notice at all no dude oh it's
been a pleasure to meet you thank you
excellent interview
you